the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
tonight on politics now what to do about
the border why nevada's senators want
one of former president trump's
controversial illegal immigration rules
to stay in place plus
there was a minority of the board that
wanted to take action and do my job
ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah
talks to us for the first time about
being fired then rehired by the school
board last year and
i've had to work with our social workers
and more times and i can even count just
because so many kids are hurting
the pandemic has left scars on children
all across the country we'll tell you
what's being done here in ccsd in the
valley to help them heal
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler we
start with nevada senator catherine
cortez masto she found herself in the
middle of the immigration debate this
week turns out she wants to keep a
measure put in place by the trump
administration and have it stay in place
title 42 is a measure enacted by a
former president trump and it allows the
government to expel migrants seeking
asylum without a hearing during a public
health emergency which are in right now
because of the pandemic in the last two
years more than 1.7 million people have
been expelled from the u.s using this
measure the centers for disease control
plans to end the use of title 42 may
23rd republicans oppose lifting it they
cite the record numbers of people at the
border right now nevada senators
catherine cortez masto and jackie rosen
also opposed lifting it at least without
a detailed plan senator cortez masto
released this statement saying quote
this is the wrong way to do this and
it'll leave the administration
unprepared for a surge at the border she
went on to say we should fix the
immigration system with border security
and treating immigrants with respect
oakland mayor libby schaff boy she set
off a firestorm this week in a morning
television interview she called las
vegas quote a gross desert her comments
came while talking about this this is
the new potential stadium site for the
oakland a's baseball team of course as
you know the team is considering moving
here to las vegas
mayor schaff's comments drew a sharp
response from local politicians governor
steve sisolak tweeted this
gift this is of course a quarterback uh
from the las vegas raiders derek carr
not the oakland raiders anymore waving
his finger no at this idea this entire
discussion also this is from
commissioner michael now from clark
county he called the mayor's comments
ignorant and elitist in las vegas mayor
carolyn goodman she invited mayor shafta
come here check out the city and yes
maybe attend a las vegas raiders game
we'll see where that goes
in other political news the supreme
court now has its first black woman
justice on the high court federal
appeals court judge katanji brown
jackson was confirmed this week by the
senate few republican senators joined
democrats in a 53-47 vote all democrats
included nevada's two senators
catherine cortez masto and jackie rosen
they all voted for her
i'm the father of a young black girl
i know how much it means
for judge jackson
to have navigated the double jeopardy of
racism and sexism to now stand in the
glory of this moment based on her record
i believe she will prove to be
the furthest left
of any justice to have ever served on
the supreme court
that's texas republican senator ted cruz
he and other republicans say justice
jackson is soft on crime she's the first
former public defender to sit on the
supreme court justice brown jackson
replaces outgoing justice stephen breyer
clark county school district
superintendent dr jesus jarrah and the
school board as you know have had a
contentious relationship last year dr
jarrah was fired then re-hired by the
board of trustees well he recently sat
down with politics now for an in-depth
discussion about what happened from his
point of view late last year i don't
have to remind you you were fired
and rehired by the school board
i think there are some lingering aspects
of that issue that the public still
maybe needs some answers on i certainly
have my own questions about it but first
and foremost why did you stay at ccsd
why did i stay you know i'm going to
tell you because what i see in our kids
i see myself in them
i was that kid i was a student that you
know i had to work
to you know support my mom my mom's
sixth grade education
raising five kids by herself
i was that urban kid
and it was a school system that got me
to where i am today it was the teachers
that helped me and supported me i had
counselors i had very good ones and i
had some that were not so good right so
then it kind of pushed me and propelled
me into
who i am
as a leader and as a father so
um i love this community this is my
community
and and i love the kids i do love the
messiness and we got a lot of work to do
and we have a great team um that's doing
some great things
for
us to improve the school system here
but what happened i mean we can watch
the school board meetings as well i mean
you were there obviously
what happened
that's a question for the board well
woman from your point of view what
happened i mean
you weren't blindsided you saw this
coming i mean you had to see this coming
down the pipe i i you know i could tell
you i work for the board
um and from my perspective and i'll just
you know be candid with you and and with
the community and i said i said it in my
statement there was a minority of the
board that wanted to take action
do my job
as a superintendent you work for the
board of trustees all seven
and and you know that's kind of where my
position was all along and it still is i
i have
the officers up from the majority of the
board that are focused on on students
we're we're addressing and we're really
looking at the needs i mean we have for
the first time in my tenure
since 2018 that now we're talking about
student outcomes at board meetings
that's a welcome um for me and for the
team
the board is basically the same right
now as it was back in october november
last year did it ever cross your mind to
not come back to clark county school
district it was um sometimes it did and
but you know i i felt the
the team that was in place
um the principals the staff
and there's opportunities i said it last
night um you know there's opportunities
that come all the time
but i i see that we are at this cups
cusp
of really moving this district forward
for the first time in a long time
okay i may just be stubborn
well i know you said that last night too
i saw um how would you describe the
relationship with the board now i think
we have a really good working
relationship
we'll see where it goes certainly
covered a lot more about ccsd in the
interview with dr jarry you can watch it
right now at eightnewsnow.com it's well
worth a watch
speaking of ccsd seats on the clark
county school board that have clashed
with dr jarrah they're up for
re-election this year all three
incumbent trustees initially voted to
fire him board chair current board chair
irene zepeda of course she changed her
mind which is how the superintendent got
his job back she has four challengers
that includes fernando romero he runs
the popular republican-leaning hispanics
and politics program stephen conger is
another candidate he is with the group
power to parent also running for that
seat district f trustee danielle ford
she has competition from nine different
people that includes former
assemblywoman irene bustamante adams and
jay calhoun he's a computer tech at ccsd
and football coach at desert oasis high
school
former board president linda cavazos has
six challengers and they include chuck
summers a maintenance supervisor at ccsd
john carlo a man who calls himself ghost
patriot 1776
also running and adam larosa a candidate
who says he wants cameras in classrooms
it's important though to note how school
board elections work here in clark
county it's a non-partisan seat everyone
in the primary runs against each other
in their districts the top two go under
the general election so let's take a
look at the primary election the primary
involving current board trustee katie
williams for district b in the 2020 race
there was no incumbent and no
overwhelming favorite williams got the
highest vote total back then with 23.9
percent
and then went into a runoff with jeff
profit who had 18.7 percent and beat him
in the general election
someone can win outright if they get
more than 50 percent of the vote in the
in the first go round
an alarming mental health crisis among
america's youth it only got worse during
the coronavirus pandemic a new study by
the
cscdc found one in five teenagers early
in the pandemic consider taking their
own life lelia luciano shows us what
clark county school district is doing to
save lives
in nicholas orr's las vegas high school
classroom he's teaching more than
science
right where it says add file i'll be the
first to tell you you matter you are
loved you are never alone orr says his
students returned from remote learning
different i've had to work with our
social workers more times than i can
even count just because so many kids are
hurting and grieving in the clark county
school district alone at least 30
students have died by suicide since the
pandemic began nationwide the cdc says
44 percent of america's high school
students reported they persistently felt
sad or hopeless in the past year
to confront the challenge the clark
county school district started a weekly
social and emotional learning lesson
honestly it does help a lot like just
that moment of like five minutes of
talking about
oh today was not the best day we met
sierra vista high school students
maurice alex and giovanna as they
discussed the topic of belonging now
that we're all back i feel like a lot of
people are more like they're not as
willing to like
just like talk to someone new what was
the impact of that what are you seeing
happening in the school people feeling
alone i guess like they don't really
have that many friends or they feel like
they lost a lot of people
principal jessica lovell brings a
therapy dog to school every day and says
her teachers know the job takes more
than what's required well i think it
goes back to that teacher as a as kind
of have to wear different hats so am i
teaching right now am i a therapist
right now am i talking kids down right
now am i talking about what's happening
in the world
nick orr knows the consequences of
missing the signs of distress if i
didn't see this in my own brother
someone with who i was
living with how am i going to see it in
someone that i see for 84 minutes
every other day
in august of 2020 nick's 18 year old
brother anthony was among those 30
students the district lost to suicide he
had just graduated he was popular yeah
popular he kept everything
hidden
and on his phone and or
well he didn't
he didn't vocalize when he needed help
saving others is now his mission we need
to take a lot of pressure off kids as
far as grades and academics and put more
pressure on happiness and well-being and
just it's okay to not be okay
as long as you have a plan to get back
to okay
for ion america lilia luciano
if you or someone you know is in
emotional distress or a suicidal crisis
look at the number on your screen is the
national suicide prevention hotline
1-800-273-talk 1-800-273-8
next on politics now how vulnerable are
we to cyber attacks i'll speak with the
unlv professor on just how prepared our
casino industry is for a potential
attack from russia
and dealing with long-term symptoms of
coronavirus the new plan to learn about
how we are dealing with long-haul coats
information go to shop hot tubs.com
welcome back to politics now
ukrainian officials are urging people in
the eastern part of that country to
evacuate to get out of the way as russia
sends more troops there the mayor of
mario poll estimates 5 000 troops have
been killed by russia and now russia
says that is where it plans to
concentrate its troops its forces
meanwhile here in the u.s the senate
unanimously passed a bill this week to
strip russia of its most favored nation
status
the legislation will go a long way to
landing a painful severe blow on putin's
economy it will hinder his ability to
keep funding his war machine
this week president joe biden announced
new sanctions against russia's largest
banks and the two grown daughters of
president vladimir putin
cyber security experts are worried
russia could retaliate against these
sanctions with online attacks i spoke
with unlv professor and cyber security
expert greg moody
what is happening in the in the cyber
warfare world right now
that
governments
here in las vegas resorts
are watching and should be worried about
yeah so cyber security just like any
other industry goes through trends
and so various years the the main
attackers within cyber security they
just start targeting new things because
once they start targeting one industry
they threaten those attacks and they
block it
but other industries haven't been
targeted such as so then they shift
industries they start targeting the
exact same attacks because
they already have the tools they already
know how to do it and different
companies are therefore not protected so
they start hopping around
until basically they picked all the same
fruit from the different trees in the
orchard
russia particularly the russian mafia is
a very known purveyor of cyber attacks
they have a large industry where they
just target the western world
and they steal information how do they
do that
um
targeted attacks and they are one of the
main purveyors of dropping malware and
they're the ones that have the bot nets
which is once they take control of
machines so they drop malware all over
the place when you go to those sites you
get infected and they can take your
hardware resources
and they'll get large botnets of 80 000
to 150 000 different machines
and they will sell that out to people to
then do their own attacks or to run
phishing email scams
and basically they've taken your
hardware and they rent out to others to
other attacks
how far ahead or behind would you say we
are here in the us to those
entities overseas that are trying to
poke around and fish and spread spread
malware everywhere
right so everything's cyclical
as soon as they do an attack we get a
defense
the main companies they push it out we
patch it we protect it
and generally i'd say our readiness is
decently well
um
the most advanced attacks that have been
perpetuated in the world have um
not officially been announced that they
were us
but unofficially everyone recognizes
like the large attacks that were
launched against iran to other nuclear
facilities
that was with us in israel
how hard is the
effort to try and
get people trained
to work in this field right now so
locally regionally um cyber security was
not a big deal for a while
ironically the casinos will back this up
when i moved here 2011 i was like oh let
me reach out ask about like how's your
assignments created like we don't do
anything like what do you mean you don't
do anything like
we have the gaming control board
if they're happy with us then we're
happy that means we're good
and for like years like there's a
payment card industry like the credit
cards free to accept credit cards you
have to have certain industry standards
they didn't meet them
they just said we're going to pay them
to find that's a lot cheaper
than updating all of our processes and
systems and data to be in compliance
with your security standards the way
you're describing it makes it seem like
las vegas is
it's kind of a blind spot when it comes
to cyber security is that is that a fair
assessment or is is it catching up
so people do what they're motivated to
do by the incentive structure
casinos were dominated by the gaming
control boards of nevada they said you
have to do these to do gaming
so that's what they did
you didn't have to do any more
next on politics now democrats putting
their money where their mouth is we'll
look at why they're making their biggest
investment in three local congressional
seats
sponsored by albertsons and bonds
you're watching politics now
congressional democrats have their
sights set on holding onto three house
seats here in southern nevada the house
majority pack earmarked more than 11 and
a half million dollars to defend seats
held by house members dina titus susie
lee and steven horsford that's the most
earmarked for any city in the country
in the senate race republican candidate
adam laxalt has come out in support of
florida's controversial new law about
teaching gender identity in schools
democrats have called it don't say gay
that measure republicans say though this
prevents teaching about sexual
orientation to those under third grade
other states like ohio and texas they're
adopting similar bills right now it's
worth pointing out another republican in
the senate race is sam brown and he has
a new ad buyout right now
after 30 surgeries years of recovery
turns out i'm hard to kill i've built a
family a small business a grassroots
movement
that is the voice of sam brown this ad
you're going to see it on local
television stations you'll see it on fox
news if you watch that brown as you may
know was injured by an ied attack in
afghanistan while he served
what are the long-term side effects for
people who have had coronavirus a new
effort is underway from the bite
administration right now to try and find
out the department of health and human
services is looking into the effects and
trying to create a plan a national plan
of action virginia senator tim kaine
says he's one of the millions of
americans feeling long coveted symptoms
i had more like a
blizzard of allergic reactions
but one of them was sort of
instantaneously i felt like all my nerve
endings were tingling
talk about efforts to tackle long covet
alex simone from washington d.c
alex what are some of the long-term
symptoms that are being seen right now
well the secretary of health and human
services javier becerra talked about
that a lot this week and he says it
really is just such a wide range of
symptoms that are linked to what's now
being called long covet or long-haul
coveted
and they can vary from things like
allergic-like reactions rash-like
symptoms
to very serious things like heart
palpitations or irregular heart beating
there's also been a lot of reports of
people's mental health being impacted by
these long coveted symptoms the kind of
alarming thing about wong covet is that
it can impact people
in really different ways and like i said
some of the symptoms can be even
neurological so some serious symptoms
that we're talking about all right so
let's talk about what's being done in
this plant to try and figure out more
about law encode and how to treat it
yeah so some senators including senator
tim kaine had introduced a bill to try
to fund efforts to deal with long covid
so far that's only in the beginning
stages but this week secretary javier
becerra announced that president biden
tasked health and human services with
leading this
nationwide effort essentially that will
involve a lot of different government
departments to to try to deal with long
covet and it will involve things like
improving the care services and support
that people get when they are dealing
with it also enhancing education and
outreach because a lot of people who may
be dealing with these changes in their
in their health
or health impacts they may not know that
it's necessarily linked to covet or to
their previous covet diagnosis and so
education and outreach is a big part of
that
and then also advancing research because
this is all still so new you know there
isn't it's not like there's one test you
can give people to figure out whether or
not they're dealing with long covid um
it's really a complex issue and will
likely have to involve a process of
testing and elimination of various other
diseases to try to figure out if that's
what people are dealing with
and that was alex simone from washington
d.c
now
this week in what to watch the slow move
towards legal pot lounges clark county
commissioners will hold a public meeting
on cannabis consumption lounges april
19th
on the table for discussion how many
lounges hours of operations distance
requirements from schools for example
all up for debate on monday the state
board of education will meet and one of
the topics getting ccsd in compliance
with the state reorganization law
the state says essentially too many
decisions are going through the central
office at clark county school district
and not at the local school level we'll
follow that next week but that will do
it for us this week on politics now more
news at eight newsnow dot com we're back
next saturday thank you for watching
[Music]